[Musik]
das gebäude der autobahnpolizei in baden
württembergischen kißlegg hat eine neue
fassade bekommen schicke solarmodule
senkrecht verbaut statt flach auf dem
dach der ganz besondere kniff sie sind
beweglich und drehen sich zur sonne aber
kein witz sie tun das nicht automatisch
nein sie müssen jeden tag und immer
wieder per hand neu ausgerichtet werden
ihre dass ein hausmeister des nach der
sony 3 musste total bescheuert es ist
sinnvoller solaranlage zum bauer
aber man sollte ja so bauer darf man
nicht mehr arbeit hatten soll ja so was
mal weniger arbeit hat und die energie
nutzer kann ohne dass man arbeite
einsetzt um die zum die photovoltaik
plattendreher es war viel zu eng im
polizeirevier in kißlegg deshalb wird
2016 dieser anbau aus sichtbeton und
lochblech dran gesetzt
gekostet hat das stolze 360.000 euro
das ganz besondere etwas aber sind diese
20 solarmodule an der südseite die
extravagante fassade dient als
sonnenschutz für die büros gleichzeitig
wird damit umweltfreundlich energie
gewonnen
prima idee sollte man meinen aber das
kostet richtig muskelkraft denn die
schicken module müssen per hand in
richtung sonne gedreht werden was sonst
heutzutage einfacher elektromotoren
erledigen ist in kißlegg mühsamer
handarbeit jeden tag immer wieder im
baden württembergischen
finanzministerium heißt es die
solaranlage die ihn in erster linie
nicht der energiegewinnung sondern
vielmehr dem wohlbefinden der
mitarbeiter als teil des gebäudes dient
sie zugleich den sonnenschutz und da
kann man jetzt wie jeder andere in einem
büro mit einer markise oder ähnliches um
ähnlichen vorm fenster auch manuell
regeln wie die sonne strahlt oder auch
nicht warum baut man teure und
handbetriebene solarmodule ein wo es ein
paar markisen auch getan hätten
da macht man sich viel aufregen was der
staat macht das geld nun schmeißt und
schwer verdientes geld dort steirer hat
der für solche sache doch noch ich finde
es total die dummheit dass man sowas
überhaupt in auftrag geben kann es das
steuerverschwendung das könnte man
woanders einsetzen das geld und ich
denke man sollte man eine andere lösung
finden
das komplette dach einfach mit
solarmodulen zupflastern und für die
einzelnen fenster jalousien das wäre mit
sicherheit preiswerte und effizienter
gewesen stattdessen hat die
autobahnpolizei jetzt eine schicke
fassade und der hausmeister jede menge
arbeit zusätzlich